je m'appelle et me arsenault je suis une
maman plusieurs des banques j'étais une
maman mais je suis je resterai une maman
jusqu'à l'infini
ce n'est pas parce qu'il vous a acheté à
moi que ça vous change un millier alex
miles fisher votre maman j'ai pas de
mots pour vous dire à quel point que je
m'ennuie chaque seconde
mais particulièrement avant d'aller
dormir sa chemise à meaux qu'il n'y a
pas eu soin ou que je vais pas me borie
comme si j'avais encore la chance de
vous avoir près de moi je continue de
vous dire que je vous aime que je vous
adore pour les lier à la folie
multiplient tout comme avant goût de
venir des étoiles olivier mon p'tit loup
j'aimerais tellement encore tentant de
reprendre comme que je les écoute et un
petit loup mais pour un petit loup et le
renard comme ta classe en maternelle qui
pouvoir rire avec toi comment savait si
bien le faire dans un jeu tellement
contente d arrêter de voir à l'école je
dis à ma tous arrivent pour avoir un
bisou je m'ennuie vraiment toi mais
jamais pas encore ce que ça voulait
vraiment ennuyer toi ce moment le lx
c'est en détention d'un pressoir et
passionnelle commençait tout juste à
répéter notre je t'aime je t'adore phare
demander encore et encore j'aimais
tellement ce temps dans le droit comme
c'était la première fois qu'on le disait
à chaque fois avant celui que je n'aurai
plus la chance d'aller coller un peu
trop coûteux courir après pour un
dernier bisou
je serai jamais sur ta chambre te saoule
les soirs sont pénibles quand les
souvenirs m'envahissent mais si vous
saviez comme les matins sont difficiles
aussi
quand je me rappel au début de journée
en devançant en écoutant de la musique
tout en famille mes journées seront plus
jamais pareil qui commenceront plus
jamais de façon ciblée douce je
m'habille serait jamais à votre absence
ni au vide que votre départ les 100 m
j'étais je suis chez les votre maman
pour toujours mes cocos je vous aime à
l'infini plus que les mots peux me
permettre de l'exprimer
depuis que c'est arrivé j'ai vite limité
le plus possible
c'est comme un cauchemar éveillé pour
moi j'avais trop la peine j'en ai encore
mieux si je décide de parler aujourd'hui
c'est parce qu'en plus d'appels
j'ai vraiment beaucoup de colère j'ai
besoin qu'on m'attend je suis en colère
comme notre québec est doté d'un système
de protection à l'enfance
pis moi quand j'ai fait appel à la dpj
pour protéger mes propres enfants
ils étaient où ce système de protection
le pourquoi on m'a pas entendu
pourquoi tous les signalements pour mes
amours ont peu été reconnue malgré tout
notre bon vouloir
pourquoi la travailleuse sociale de
l'hôpital bilan qui est temps qu'ils
étaient censés nous avions peu plus on
peut et écrous sérieux cas qui ont
signalé aux moustiques
pourquoi il faut attendre que quelqu'un
s'en prennent à nos enfants quand tous
les signes avant coureurs sont le
pourquoi la violence familiale et fo
pris au sérieux quand la maman est là
pour éponger qui protégeait ses enfants
jusqu à la fois de trop
la seule fois où il a touché à mes
enfants cité dans la nuit du 10 au 11
octobre
si vous nous aviez écouté j'irai
peut-être la chance de profiter de mon
dimanche aujourd'hui avec mes enfants
plutôt quelle librairie
il oppose spécialiste en intervenant qui
m'a pas posé la question est-ce que tu
crains pour la vie de ses enfants dans
ma tête à moi ça se peut pas qu'un
parent s'en prenne à ses enfants
est ce qu'on peux m'en vouloir d'avoir
répondu je peux pas croire qu'il s'en
prendre à ses propres enfants mais je me
suis trompé comme l'aigle de martin
carpentier en 2020 comme la proche des
petites victimes de granby en 2020 comme
l'église de patrick des hôtels en 2012
comme l'ex de catégorie en 2009 comme
l'ex de guy turcotte en 2009 aussi et
comme beaucoup trop d'autres enfants
j'ai tout fait ce que j'ai pu mais je
vais vous pouvez pas porter sur les
épaules tout seul j'avais besoin de
systèmes pour qui m'appuient quiconque
croit des départs ans et se pose être
une équipe s'ils se poser prendre soin
de ce qu'ils ont de plus précieux à
parts égales mais ça ne se passe pas
toujours comme ça si un parent inquiet
il devrait être entendu soutenu est pris
au sérieux
ça fait aucun sens que j'étais obligé de
faire venir la police tout cela n'est
pas fait pour empêcher de partir avec
les pour l'empêcher spartak les enfants
en espérant obtenir une ordonnance de
sauvegarde
mais vu que j'avais pas de jugement de
la cour la poubelle la foulée la police
pouvait rien voir
donc ils pu partir avec olivier quand
même ça fait aucun sens que mon havre
comme ai répondu quand j'ai demandé pour
leur garde exclusive
vous savez un juge dans les wsop à la
gare dans le port en se basant sur vos
simple inquiétudes demeurent savez vous
ce que j'ai répondu après qu'ils me
disent que c'est à cause d'eux des
contextes comme ce week-end de 12 ans
qui a tout qui sont pas écoutés qu'il ya
des enfants qui meurent de nos jours
j'étais des cocos découragé j'ai voulu
changer d'avocat mais j'ai pas eu le
temps parce que cette conversation le
jeu l'aigu le 8 octobre avec mon avocat
trois jours avant dans un contexte de
violence familiale ça brûle quand on
décide de parler on doit être entendu
maintenant qu'ils recevoir de lettre
maintenant va tomber sur une boîte
vocale pas tomber sur une liste
d'attenté plus de sens
la violence c'est aussi de la
manipulation des menaces c'est d'avoir
quelqu'un qui brise notre confiance en
nous c'est d'être déchiré en vouloir
tout faire pour protéger nos enfants que
les voir aimer l'autre parent
quand même c'est de devoir expliquer à
nos enfants qui ont le droit d'aimer
leurs deux parents malgré tout c'est de
ne plus savoir quoi faire de plus quand
on décide de porter plainte c'est pas
deux mois plus tard la police de nous
téléphoner pour faire le suivi
la violence ça prend pas de congés est à
nos portes 24h 24 365 jours par année
je l'apprends me dépasse on devrait
pouvoir recevoir de l'aide peut être
perçue comme une victime même si bonne
ou directement qui a reçu le coup fatal
est ce que c'est normal que la famille
ne se peu reconnus comme des victimes
elles aussi
alors qu'on dise arraché violemment ce
qu'on avait de plus précieux
on est des jeunes car lourdes avoir
autant de pin si vous saviez comment
l'énergie nous manque pour mener cette
bataille et faire reconnaître tes vrais
victimes de violences
on a besoin d'être entendue puis j'ai
envie de décrier à tout le monde à quel
point que je trouve très injuste
j'ai la chance d'avoir beaucoup d'amis
une famille qui est le pont supporter
mais je sais que c'est pas toutes les
victimes de violence familiale qui ont
cette chance
c'est autant pour moi que pour eux que
je veux mener cette bataille il le faut
plus que j'aime
il faut plus jamais qu'un parent et
habite malgré tout je suis qui reste du
bon je sais que derrière notre système
malade au québec il ya des intervenants
qui font de leur mieux pour aider
donc je veux prendre le temps de dire
merci aux services de police de wendake
et qui dans le meilleur de leurs
compétences ont agi rapidement piqué
m'ont toujours soutenu ammann bellemare
de m'aider me supporter dans cette
épreuve à mes collègues de travail qui
m'ont écouté puis soutenu au travers des
années difficiles
vous avez fait une différence à la
communauté douanes d'accueil qui nous
ont accueillis mais enfin et moi bras
ouverts
iq sont encore le pont supporter dans
les moments difficiles à mes amis et ma
famille sont là depuis toujours qui
m'ont aidé à sortir de cette relation
malsaine là il ya deux ans et qui ont
tout fait pour notre bien à moi et mes
enfants
merci d'être encore logement
je remercie aussi mon conjoint qui m'a
aidé à rester debout quand moi je suis
plus capable de faire et qui met peau
depuis plus d'un an
merci de mai mais avec mes cicatrices
invisible merci à vous tous aujourd'hui
d'être merci d'entendre mon ultime appel
à l'aide
j'espère sincèrement que vous servirez
de votre pouvoir pour faire bouger les
choses dans la mémoire lié à l'x mes
doutes des toiles